kevin o'leary is best known as the
prickly merchant of truth on CBC's
Dragons Den as well as on ABC's Shark
Tank he's also built a software company
that was acquired for more than four
billion dollars and now runs O'Leary
funds an investment firm with assets of
more than 1.5 billion he joins me today
to talk about his latest venture
launching his own open welcome Kevin
great to be here Natalie thank you how
high terrific Before we jump into your
own wines um tell me can you remember
the first wine that you ever tasted I
can you know my dad who Swiss and lives
in Geneva loves Pinot and he's got a
huge careful of Burgundy's I think
remarkably one of the first ones I ever
tasted was a 1960 tool attached which
you know is a really bad place to start
because it doesn't get any better than
that I think he really polluted me and
gave me a you know sort of a feeling for
how how down i can go from there that's
the real problem because you don't want
latesh to become your favorite wine you
just can't afford it anymore no you
either have to do that or start your own
investment fund to afford that kind of
taste well touche um so what druid one
was it that wine or was it another wide
experience that really made you say hey
wine is something I want to know more
about learn about that sort of thing it
was always part of my family so you know
we would have y even when I was a young
child it did five or six because in
Europe they generally give you wine a
little bit so that it's not something
that's you're not used to and I think
that's actually a very good culture
because I didn't drink excessively ever
and it was so much part of my family all
the way through that I just got used to
it so wine has been a natural element to
all my meals I've always enjoyed it I
hope you know I don't drink it
excessively although I love it so much
but I do the same thing with my children
I've been introduced in the women at
young age my daughter has really taken
to it she's actually very good my my
what my wife is is very interested in
wines and actually manages our five
sellers we have now I have a lot of wine
as an investment and I by aggressively
the I've got a really deep seller of
Burgundy's Bordeaux's and Californians
and I just sort of extended into the
Italians now with some super tuscans
that I'm enjoying so you know at the end
of the day it's one of the most
wonderful hobbies you can have it brings
family together friends together and
above all that it's great to drink good
wine absolutely and just before I move
on to the next question five sellers
approximately how many bottles you know
I probably am less than 10,000 because
I'm very very selective a few thousand
in each seller but you know what I'm
looking for is and i buy with a group of
five of us who are always on the lookout
around the world for opportunities you
know I think if some of the greatest
purchases I've made or what I call
divorced sellers but it would is you
know men and women separate and they
can't agree on the wine and they look
for a buyer to buy the whole thing out
recently in Boston that happened to me
and David and I went to my my by
partners we got up at five in the
morning and went through a cellar it was
massive and we bring our technology with
us our wireless computers we want to be
fair about the prices we offer we know
the world price options for everything
we bought that entire cellar and it took
us two trucks to move it and it was just
so much fun doing it and of course we
helped that couple out because we gave
them liquidity in a market I think is in
some ways they're expensive auctions of
wine generally cost fifteen to twenty
percent of the value just through the
auction process if you get a buyer like
me to come and get it you save a lot of
money wow I was going to say that sounds
like vulture capital but I guess you
were helping those people out to trade
their liquid assets for other liquid
assets of what gave you the idea what
when did you first get the idea to
launch your own wine brand well you know
i love i love wines and i'm always
interested in exploring new ideas in
wine and you know for 20 years here in
ontario we were a backwater you know I'm
a proud Canadian I live I at least have
a home here in Toronto I spent a fair
amount of time two days a week here and
so what I've always watched over the
years is the progression from being a
a relatively unknown place let's face it
20 years ago at Niagara primarily was
growing love Bruce got grapes which are
terrible I mean you make jam with that
stuff you go blind if you drink the wine
that's me just an awful and and what's
happened is the climate's changed and
some really great wines are being grown
now by some very capable Venters and so
you take Pinot front for example the
climate is perfect for that grape in
Ontario and lately in the last five
years we've had some amazing you know
francks that have come out of here and I
think you can get a classic Bordeaux
blend right out of Ontario and that's
what I wanted to do I wanted to do a
couple of things launch myself into the
wine business because I've always wanted
to do that particularly with a cab land
and I love chardon ease in the summer so
I thought I'd just do too and I went
looking for a partner luckily I have a
brand name that I enjoyed doing multiple
businesses with O'Leary funds O'Leary
mortgages I thought why not only rewinds
and we've been relatively successful the
only been on the market a couple of
months we've won five international
awards on our cab blend so believe me
I'm I'm licking my chops I'm liking this
hahaha no but you're a cash flow kind of
guy Kevin why not spirits where the
margins might be greater well you know I
think you can go there Natalie but I
think it's more delicate to develop a
brand around something that I love I
don't drink that much spirit liquor you
know it's it's occasionally I have a
vodka soda but my real love is is is
developing my evening with a great crisp
Chardonnay or Montrachet when I get home
from work that's my idea of a cocktail
and then with dinner a fantastic bottle
of red that I enjoy with my family so
you know hard liquors not part of my my
fiber and so that's not where I want to
go I want to be able to stand up to
people and say listen I have created a
wine for you that it's so spectacular in
value that I could i want you to compare
it to anything else you buy the same
price that's what the O'Leary brand is
all about that's what I wanted to do and
why okay fair enough but why not a
Montrachet I know you're proud Canadian
but but what was it from a business
perspective that made you say okay uh
Niagara well what I wanted that Lee was
consistency if I bring a wine and you
try it once I want and you take it from
the first case I want it to be as good
on the 10,000th case so I need access to
you know quantity that I know is going
to have consistent quality I don't think
that's eat that easy to do with a
Montrachet in ontario's you know I think
that's one thing also explaining to the
market when a Montrachet is versus a
Chardonnay in some ways are the same
thing it's not that easy right now the
fastest-growing category and I've done a
lot of research on this hour uh no
chardonnays people are getting tired of
the heavy buttery you know challenging
your own food flavor of a heavy oak
Chardonnay and I thought let me bring an
unknow cardin a Montrachet ish if you
would if you will if you you know go
with me on this Chris almost with a with
an element of a Swiss phone dawn an
effervescence a yeasty kind of thing
happening there and I was describing
that to my wife and to the guys you know
at vine land estates Brian and Alan I
said can we get there can we blend an
unknow chardon a that that I'd want to
sell and we spent a lot of time on that
shard till one day I just I just tasted
it said this is it and that's what we
went with it has been very well received
so I'm trying to introduce people to
different ideas when it comes to white
for years here in Ontario heavy old
shard was the way to go now this
category is growing I want to be part
okay and why not a premium like a 35
fifty-dollar niagara Chardonnay great
question is that's where I wanted to go
so here's what I learned when I started
doing research because this is also a
business venture for me I have employees
working on it i want to be successful
when i enter into a business i want to
be competitive and i want to win that's
what i do and everything I work so i
started doing some research i sat down
with the people to lcbo and says let's
talk about price point i thought i'd
want to come out at around a 48 dollar
price point to the white they said
you're crazy here's why ninety-seven
percent of wines purchased in ontario
are under $19 a bawd the sweet spot is
1495 if you want a garner massive market
share quickly you want to be 14 95 so
effectively
what happened is I took what I thought
was a fifty dollar bottle and brought it
out in 14 95 and the guys at the lcbo
right because you can't get a permanent
listing at a crazy high price point it
can't get a permanent listing if you're
not vqa and you want a primitive with
secret there's over 600 up lcbo stores
so I'm in 120 now I'm rolling out
another hundred I'm doing a lot of
tastings the customers I'm enjoying the
marketing process but understanding the
market is very important if you're going
to launch a wine and gain market share
so it's 1495 for the white unoaked
chardonnay and 1495 for the cab blend
those are very good price points because
I think they're both worth fifty dollars
of all spoken like a true marketer why
did you go with the vine land estates
why not a bigger distribution arm based
in Niagara you know wow it's a great
question that Lee and believe me we
spent a year doing due diligence with
all the parts all the potential partners
you know the guys at Vineland really
care about the product they have an
emotional attachment to their that
process the land they've done this on
their building capacity they had the
production capabilities when I did due
diligence with the lcbo and many of the
fine restaurants I like to dine in
everybody love those guys so
relationships and wine matter more than
any other business you gotta trust your
partner you've got to like your partner
and all the people involved the
distribution process have to like them
too they came out with flying colors and
not to say we didn't go far down the
road with some other bigger players but
the consistency of the product I mean
Brian understood i said look I put my
name on it I want to drink it and I
don't want people to open the bottle and
find one tastings different than another
that just blows my brand up I can't have
that happen I believe they can do what I
need to do I think they can expand with
me I you're going to find this wine all
over Canada as in some very interesting
call marketing deals I'm working on
right now luckily I enjoy a very large
audience on television many other
companies want to work with me on that
and radio and we're doing a lot of
cooperative marketing around both wines
in the next year so no more pepsi or
coffee on the on the table during the
broadcasts you can have a glass of wine
with you absolutely well cheers to that
Kevin thanks for chatting with me
I want to come back again and of course
taste your wines with you ask you a few
more questions but I appreciate your
time great thank you Natalie all right